如何提高你的收入
给大家一个非常具体,非常市草
里边有相信不做的方法
简单的正在小钱
分成三个层次
第一个层次其实就是打工
我们大部分都处在价格状态
当然其中很多人的这个思维是受限的
我给大家久了一次
就是我比较早的一份工作
时间不长
但是是给我们领导当通讯员
我是怎么得到这份工作呢
就是我们上一个通讯员
特别紧张
因为通讯员
给领导干嘛
就是到个水
插个桌子
然后交个花
再把领导报纸
对吧
之类的这样的一些工作
但他就非常的紧张
非常的紧张
就你去于工作
工作不了了
就之前他们有人开过一个玩笑
我应该说的不是他
但这是个惡意的玩笑
上位声音的时候看得领导了
领导你亲自来唱说出来
我认为这不是他
但是确确实是我们很多人的真实的学生
就是他认为他的前程来自于领导的
是来自于老板的
对吧
但是实际上真实的情况是什么
真实的情况是我们和老板之间
是价值交换
就是我给你提供器的
然后我用我的劳动所得来获取收入
我我一定会有人吃反对一些
不要紧反对就是你对
这是一个记录记录先说
现在我来个点还讲怎么突破的
怎么突破呢
当你明白了这个道理
就是你是靠什么赚钱
你是通过你的劳动所得
你给你用个技能
给这个公司提供价值来获取劳动所得
如果你能够明白这个道理的话
那么好的下一步就有了
你是不是可以把你的这个技能
卖给第二个人
就卖给第二个用过
不一定是你的公司
但是你马上就遇到一个问题
什么问题
就是他的时间是有限的
比如说我是早上
八点钟上班了
下午晚上的时候
六点钟才回来
对不对
或者七八点钟才回来
你要去卖给卖给卖一个公司
你实际上是冲突的
那怎么办
你可以从大零公开始
这个时候可以打零公开始
有些地方比如说你晚上的时候
八点钟的时候干活
或者是周末的时候干活
有没有呢
有
你比如说像那个
周末这样那个网站
昨天就有人问了
你想他的一小时
大概是三十到
三十到那周客人闭的话
两个都要钱嘛
对不对
你也可以去那个
U.S.Testing
然后他大概是多少钱
二十多到二十八到百二十
记得
然后周客人闭多少钱
你也可以去那个
Fire
有人知道吗
你可以在上面有很多零公
对什么
什么编程
什么剪机
什么文案
你对工作
上面好多
让你在上面去造工作
你刚开始
有什么正正多少钱
不是正多少钱的问题
是你要去接上面的活
你能不能接
你能接
那就说明能做这个事情
你不能接
说明你的能力有问题
各位你能明白我的意思吗
你一直人没有
老板跟我发到时候
实际上是因为你的能力不足一直成
那么你出去上面去接活
那么你接到活之后的话
你的你接到活
就会越来越多
越来越多
对吧
你有这个能力的时候
你做得也好吧
就会很能找你嘛
对不对
这个时候你就可以全航了
这是我的钱是在这工作
还是在这工作
我把我的这个技能
卖给谁跟歌诗
是这样的吗
这个时候你就选择了
注意
你以前的时候是
把一份技能卖给一下
一个用户
现在你是把一份技能
卖给多个用户
能理解这个道理吗
然后给大家讲的小故事吧
这个故事我估计很多人身边就有
就是外国公司
我就曾经见了我
外国公司的好多人
就接任务单
我曾经看到那个任务单
我一看那个任务单
我就知道他是来说那个网站
然后我查了一下
那个网站的那个任务的
那个只是那个钱
和他们公司给那个钱
差不多一半
那没办法我意思吗
这时候说第二个问题
你要去开始做一些
灵工做灵工的目的
不是为了政策
你是通过做灵工的目的
来干嘛
来让你的技能
搬在技能具体化
然后这个技能可以卖出很多
分去
好了
最重要的是第三步
第三步是什么
我们说是
第二步是你把你的技能卖出很多分
第三步是你把你的技能也好
支持也好
做化成产品
就购建一个产品
然后卖出去很多分
你要明白
就是你去发布了一个好
人家要的是那个结果
只是你怎么做的
不重要
关键是那个结果
只要是好东西
就OK
那么能不能直接产成这样一个结果呢
比如说
你可能直接卖一个解放
比如说是软件
就鞋号的软件
比如说某一个具体的
具体的产品
某一个具体的产品
对吧
是一本书
对
或者是一本书
你像这本书
是我两年前几的
但现在还在买
如果躺掉
躺了以后睡着了以后还在买
所以我之前一直给大家拍一条
是跟大家可能没有人能看
就是你要认真
购建一份属于你的产品
购建完这个产品
这个产品可以
就变成了资产
可以不断的转化
装化为财富
我不知道大家可以弄我的意思吗
这是我们这个
第三个部分
第一部分是
大公
你这时候你的思维是严重树现在的
第二份的话
就是你把你的这个机能
就卖出去很多份
你可以去打下灵工
当你这个灵工
接得越来越多的时候
注意的是
那好多都是刀
然后
你就有选择的
到第三步有什么
是把你这个机能也好
搬的知识也好
抓成产品
卖出去很多份
那么后面还有没有
但是当你到了第三步的时候
我们已经不用想了
你已经知道
后面该怎么转钱了